as you can tell I'm doing a late night
for many of you because I got my angels
my heart's from Jesus with me and I'm
having a phenomenal time with them but
too much drama online too much drama
online glory to the father of spirit so
let me get Rumble ready what's up
Rumble Lord to the fall share some stuff
we got a lot to talk about Rumble how
you doing guys really really rough the
days man the drama doesn't end
so guys what you can do is pray for one
another be prayed up ask the Holy Spirit
to fill us ask the spirit to use me as
his mouthpiece in spite of my sins and
Imperfections okay more drama
huh good to say everybody glory to the
father son name I just want to put post
some of these comments because they spot
on M allergies cat hair my throat made
the Holy Spirit strengthen me with
perfect Vigor strengthen my throat own
my throat every cell of my body Grant my
throat perfect health Vigor strength my
heart my arteries my lungs my
chest and to use my voice to glorify
Jesus Christ and serve you thank you
Father thank you Lord Jesus Christ thank
you Holy
Spirit lot of good
comments glory to the father mighty
name yep we got a lot to talk about you
raful fers Ricky what's up buddy what's
up
up too much drama so I'm going to be
sharing a lot maybe it's going to be a
34-hour session you know it's up to you
guys if you can hang right I don't mind
the spirit working through me if he
wants to use me may he finish the work
he begun on us to love the Lord Jesus
Christ even unto death and never fall
short of the Lord Jesus Christ we need
you father we need you Lord Jesus Christ
we need your Holy
Spirit right just going through the
comments uh
Kyle a regular wretched FX Muslim these
are regulars I wish I could make all of
you
mods right I recognize the regulars Tom
of course he's a regular lantto what's
up hey Capt Christian I thought you one
of my mods dude aren't you one of my
mods I know I'm not one of your mods
Joey caldan he's actually a syan calls
him Cal God bless you for your love and
support brother too much drama capturing
Christianity you otherwise you get
someone else here he plays a clip watch
here tell me if this guy sounds like a
babe or an arrogant jerk narcissist
plays the victim no he is an arrogant
jerk guys I met him but I was trying to
hold my tongue to keep an open door now
I want him to upload it upload our
discussion I already text him you saw it
I played the clip on the phone here this
what I said right here here's his phone
so guys put pressure on him I want it
uploaded
okay here you go I want it
uploaded all
right right
here let me show
you here's here it
is here's what I did and I played it
live put pressure I want it on
now yes brother you better believe I'm
going to share it online so I don't be
slandered so now online I called you out
I want you to upload our
conversation so now I'm live right now
you can go watch I want our debate our
discussion to be uploaded and I know
you're a man of integrity because you
claim to be a Christian upload it this
week we'll be waiting so God bless you
and I hope you humble yourself and seek
the full of Truth and stop teaching
you're not
qualified
okay yep we love you too brother and
it's called tough love discipline so now
do what is right upload it bless you and
I expect you to continue conversation
come to the fullness of the truth so
Lord bless you brother upload it the
world wants to
see okay no he didn't answer but unlike
the first message that didn't go through
because people started
like just bombarding his comment section
now see he got it look it says
kept he's got it he's heard it
tell him we want it I want it up
hopefully he'll have it in a week if he
doesn't then you know he's scared
because he got
pulverized he had not shown that he got
my messages but near the end he's like
hey what's going on man because Li
people were going to his comment section
blowing it up and then he finally
responded two hours
later okay